let's focus on jj now
what was the earliest version of jj like
how much did the character
change from draft to draft and then even
more
when evan was cast in the role the
earliest version of jj
i was moving so quickly the green light
happened and within
months i knew we had to shoot so it was
the most unusual experience i've ever
had as a writer
um you know i i wanted this
this unsung kind of hero guy who wants
to be a hero
and he's like a gamer and he does all
this like ambitious stuff on the screen
um and then he does the night shift at 7
11 and he's lost
when i'm trying to find stuff in himself
um
that you know is is kind of reflective
in the games he plays
so i knew i wanted that guy who was
funny
you know who would kind of roll with
whatever the [ __ ] happened that night
um and and also underneath it all would
just be this guy
who you know when everyone falls away
from her her mom her dad
everyone she's he's there for her you
know
along with pebbles of course um and so
i had this idea that i needed this
characters
this character is so important because
the the movie is so dark and it's
so bleak at times that without
uh jj you know it just goes into like
this durge it could go into george land
and i did not want that to happen um and
so
when i got to see evan's work for the
first time
you know and we had a conversation you
know he
uh evan is so charming and so fun
and and funny and genuine and he's a
writer you know see
the facility with kind of we were on set
and and
evan would take these jokes and make
them
so much better and he would just come up
with lines of dialogue and like these
ad-libs and you know i'd be in edit we'd
be laughing we'd be laughing on a set
we'd be laughing and edit
like it is it's such a gift to work with
an actor who can just
elevate your writing and just make the
character
better and funnier you know oh that's
very sweet thank you
blushing over there yet oh yeah yeah
it's
been this has been yeah very sweet
so i'm not sure evan how specific you
get with your
backstory work for a character but i
always like to hear about that
especially
for someone who becomes such an
important ally
to claire you know what do you think it
is about
him and his experiences in life that you
know made him
a supportive believer when no one else
in her life seemed to do that for her
i think there's a stilted sort of
development
that he's gone through you know i think
that i think that like jj at his you
know like through maybe his family
situation
hasn't really like grown or developed
into the person he's
meant to be you know he's sort of at a
limbo stage in his life
and i think that yeah we played around
with some backstory ideas about the idea
of him you know not being able to really
afford to live outside of his home maybe
he's
maybe he's still sort of like under the
sort of larger umbrella of of
of his parents and um and that sort of
like again
sort of distilled his growth in all this
um and then i think somebody walks
through the
door who needs help and needs to be
believed and needs to be believed in
and i think that something about that
resonates with
jj and his needs to be believed in as a
person
uh in his own private life in his movie
um
i like to think about you know i think
good supporting characters
are in their movie and then and
in the middle of their movie they get
distracted by someone else's movie and
that's how i like to think of when i'm
playing supportive
supporting characters because it it
gains them
uh strength independence and they're not
just ancillary to to progressing a story
and it just it builds a bit of the the
the foundation of a person so yeah so i
think that he
in his movie he's sort of like you know
listless and not sure what he wants and
then walks in through the door
is somebody who desperately needs help
and uh that applies a purpose to this
guy who sort of doesn't have one so i
think that's sort of
where it comes from to put vina on the
spot now
i love hearing when actors can
tell when a director behind the monitor
is really feeling
a take that they're doing so did you
notice veena doing anything behind the
monitor
that told you that you were on the right
track with the scene
yeah i can't remember actually the exact
scene uh
what it was but i think you walked you
walked
past me and you just put my your hand on
your shoulder and you're like oh you
know what it was it was by the mustang
uh with mike
after that scene um uh mustang yeah yeah
um and he uh put his uh she put my her
hand on my shoulder and it was just like
a nice little solid
moment i like those i mean we it's so
fast-paced and
and shooting is so it's just [ __ ]
bollocks scramble it's it's just
absolute mayhem at all times um so
uh vina always made time to make sure
that every
everybody got their little piece of like
this is great you're on the right path
and i think that's you know that's like
the leadership quality that i think is
you know super important and she
definitely did that from there
a story question for you did you always
know
specifically where they would have the
name
conversation in the series or did you
ever consider moving that around at all
yeah i mean there was a moment where we
realized i
think it was because everything was
moving so quickly
they had never exchanged names um and
and i think we ended up adr in it but
there was an eight
there was a moment where i was like wait
a minute they've never even said
their names to one another like a
formality of what we do hello my name is
blah blah
like there's no time for that and so
yeah i think we atr did
something i think we did too i think it
was it wasn't it in the bedroom stuff
i think it was yeah and which was a
really yeah and again
this the pace of this i i i just think
it's great
it's really entertaining and and you
know it's funny how like uh
stuff like that have they introduced it
to it
starts to not matter you know because
because of the pace and then the right
you know the thriller right
well now i remember actually we 80 yards
i think your last name
we 80 are right right yeah yeah my last
name because i did i was just
j yeah that's what it is because i know
that we did that induction scene that
little like sort of like hey oh by the
way alon cleaning her feet
like you know what i mean like that's
how intimate right i like that idea like
that's how intimate we are
already and we haven't even really
introduced each other as
as as people so that's that's a
interesting
that is some a plus adr because i
usually do have an ear for that and yeah
yeah gameplay is so
smooth and it also just speaks to what
they're going through so well so job
well done in that respect
evan before i let you go here i did kind
of go down
the rabbit hole of watching videos of
you doing
readings from mixed feelings online and
it did
get me wondering do you find that your
exploration of identity working on that
has influenced the roles that you're
gravitating towards today
i mean i feel like i've sort of
undergone a sort of a
paradigm shift as far as my
understanding of like what i'm
interested
in telling and story stories that i'm
interested in pursuing
um and again the the a lot of the
freedom of writing mixed feelings was it
was a great window into like sort of
talking about my own identity my racial
identity and
and sort of being able to uh sort of
decide what kind of roles and
parts i wanted actually i was was i not
i was in the middle of my book tour when
we were shooting this i was so
tired doing this i mean and
and everyone was really supportive and
helpful and all this stuff and
you know and forgiving but i i just come
off
doing the mixed feelings book tour i
think i fly in
directly from doing that into a complete
night shoot so i had already done
a month of traveling across the country
and then i
like it's the most tired i've ever been
in my life um but
uh but i was really well supported and
and uh
and yeah and uh i think it sort of added
to the sort of
tired feeling of the stranger and him
being ripped through this night
at four o'clock in the morning so yeah
it was uh but yeah i think mixed
feelings is
sort of uh become a sort of again a
paradigm shift for
the kind of parts that i'm looking at
you got to keep delivering the content
to the people
even if you're exhausted i can tell you
from my perspective at least it's worth
all the time
thank you guys so much again for
chatting with me multiple times today
i keep staying safe and congrats on the
series
thank you gary thanks so much